hey all Peter Kumble feed roses here
with some of the changes for you you
should be on the lookout for blood Ultra
Street Fighter 4 drops you've given
reuse some new tools to make it more
effective bullet on the ground in the
air so let's get into it
reuse jumping middle punch has been a
staple attacks in Super Street Fighter 2
turbo and a Street Fighter 4 series
however this attack has always felt
lacking as mentioned by Ryu players to
make this attack more exciting and
effective this jumping middle punch has
been changed so that it is now special
cancelable on the first hit this opens
up new funny--i damaging possibilities
to use this going up or down that's the
real question are you sure you can
attack as one of those specials that you
really love the fusing Ryu I really hate
and fighting him due to the perceived
high reward and low risk associated with
it to address this for you is more
punishable when the player attempts to
focus - counsel forward after a light or
medium punch uppercuts previously Ryu
players were able to throw this attack
out without having to worry about the
consequences but that's all changed we
use combo ability was decent but felt
very straightforward for you players
requested to have some kind of spice
added unfortunately no one could quite
put their finger on what that spice was
in an effort to solve this issue if the
first hit of Rios EXO you can has
canceled he is now able to connect
whichever attack you once this means
that he'll now be able to connect his
Metsu sure you can completely or
whatever else players come up with
overall Ryu is still extremely solid and
has only gotten better due to increasing
options players who have strong
fundamentals will still continue
ghibli relative whereas those who like
to play unconventionally now have the
ability to do so with the increased
utility of his eh sure you can and his
jumping little punch reuse specialist
will have their hands full creating new
ways to dispense of their opponent that
much quicker
you